schon lange tüfteln forschungsteams
weltweit daran fleisch im labor zu
produzieren stakes frikadellen oder
braten essen ohne dass dafür ein tier
sterben muss erste tests haben im labor
bereits funktioniert doch jetzt ist ein
niederländisches forschungsteam ein
riesenschritt weitergekommen und
prognostiziert dass sie schon in vier
jahren künstliches fleisch im restaurant
essen werden und es in spätestens sechs
jahren im supermarkt kaufen werden doch
die gewinnung ist mit menschlichem
vampirismus verbunden quasi wie wieso
weshalb jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen es
ist wirklich papieren vor ein paar
wochen war ich in einem veganen
restaurant in paris und habe fleisch
gegessen das schmeckte nicht nur wie
schweinemedaillons auch die textur und
alles fühlte sich so an und schmeckte
wie schweinefleisch es war absolut
köstlich und es war kein tierisches
produkt enthalten und es wirklich
überfällig kein fleisch mehr aus der
massentierhaltung zu essen die
industrielle herstellung von fleisch ist
nämlich extrem schädlich für mensch und
tier die tiere werden auf engstem raum
gehalten werden voll gestopft mit
medikamenten wie antibiotika und
hormonen ihnen werden die stäbe oder
schwänze gestutzt damit sie sich
stressbedingt nicht selbst oder andere
tiere verletzen
der massenhafte einsatz von antibiotika
fördert die entstehung von
antibiotikaresistenten keimen bei einer
infektion können wir menschen dann nur
noch eingeschränkt behandelt werden
immer wieder gibt es dazu neue
schlagzeilen in den medien und nicht
umsonst waren die
weltgesundheitsorganisation who vor
einer drohenden medizinischen
katastrophe auch für die umwelt bedeutet
die massentierhaltung eine riesige
katastrophe denn um beispielsweise ein
mastschwein heran zu ziehen braucht es
fast eine million liter trinkwasser und
zwar ganz allein um sein futter an
verbauen gefüttert wird es hauptsächlich
mit soja für dessen anbau beispielsweise
regenwälder in brasilien weichen müssen
wir haben hier schon öfter mal darüber
berichtet auch das grundwasser wird
durch die massentierhaltung verschmutzt
und zwar mit nitrat durch die gülle
werden die böden überdüngt große mengen
an stickstoff lagern sich im boden ab
und sorgen dafür dass verschiedene tier
und pflanzenarten sterben und zuletzt
wird auch der klimawandel durch die
massentierhaltung gefördert denn in den
medien
von kühen und rindern entsteht methan
und das ist als klimagas etwa 25 mal
klimaschädlicher als co2
die forschung auf der suche nach
wirklich künstlichen fleisch ist jetzt
ein ganzes stück weitergekommen
zitat wir wollen dass für die
fleischindustrie sein was das autos
kreditkarte kutsche war das sagt der
chef des kalifornischen start up
unternehmens mensch mit seiner firma ist
vor einiger zeit tatsächlich gelungen
was viele forschungsteams weltweit vor
ihn probiert hatten
fleisch künstlich herzustellen
herausforderung im moment kostet ein
kilogramm künstliches fleisch 32.000
euro im vergleich dazu ein kilo
herkömmliches rindfleisch gibt es schon
für unter zehn euro
das auch keine gute entwicklung ist
einer der investoren für das projekt
jeweils übrigens bill gates die fleisch
sucht im labor funktioniert vereinfacht
gesagt so aus dem muskelgewebe von kühen
werden stammzellen entnommen die dann
auf einer nährlösung wachsen sie
entwickeln sich zunächst zu muskelzellen
und dann zur muskelfasern und unter dem
mikroskop sind die dann tatsächlich
nicht von dem muskelfaser geflecht eines
realen stacks zu unterscheiden
um einen hamburger zu formen braucht es
etwa 20.000 solcher muskelfasern auch im
niederländischen maastricht gibt es ein
versuchslabor das hamburger lab vor vier
jahren wurden hier die ersten
künstlichen hamburger gezüchtet doch das
fleisch bestand nur aus muskelfasern es
enthält kein fett oder bindegewebe und
es war viel zu trocken auch der preis
dieses künstlich hergestellten fleisches
war unbezahlbar eine viertelmillion
dollar nämlich für den bratlinge obst da
muss ich mal kurz gucken
das übersteigt mal eben mein budget
seitdem ist das forschungsteam große
schritte vorangekommen kommen und es ist
mittlerweile in der lage komplette das
fleisch zu komponieren die muskelzellen
können mittlerweile beispielsweise aus
myoglobin produziert werden das ist der
stoff der muskeln rot einfärbt und ihnen
den typischen fleischgeschmack verleiht
leicht nach blut und metall eben auch
die finanzierung ist nun gesichert unter
den geldgebern ist beispielsweise
ergeben würden der google mit aufgebaut
hat auch wenn die experimente derzeit
noch im labor laufen
die technologie ist mittlerweile so
ausgereift dass sie auch in größeren
reaktoren stattfinden könnte damit
seinen hamburger für 10 bis 11 dollar
realistisch es auch noch etwas über mein
budget in drei bis vier jahren wollen
die niederländer ihr künstlich
hergestelltes fleisch auf den markt
bringen erst einmal in den niederlanden
selbst und in großbritannien und das
ganze hätte sicherlich große chancen auf
dem markt künstlich hergestelltes
fleisch wäre für viele dieser probleme
die lösung überhaupt doch es ist nicht
alles so toll wie es auf den ersten
blick klingt denn bisher wachsen die
muskelzellen auf einer nährstofflösung
wie aus zucker mineralien vitaminen
aminosäuren und aus dem serum des blutes
von kälber füllten besteht da werden die
forscherinnen und forscher quasi zu
vampiren denn um das serum zu gewinnen
wird das ungeborene kalb aus der
gebärmutter der kuh geholt um ihm dann
blut aus dem herzen abzusaugen
ja das geschieht ohne betäubung das kalb
überlebt diese eingriffe nicht die kuh
wird danach geschlachtet ja zum anderen
beinhaltet das ganze auch ein gewisses
risiko denn das serum könnte krankheiten
übertragen und so sind forschungsteams
weltweit auf der suche nach alternativen
eine basis könnte beispielsweise könnten
pflanzen wie algen extrakt um bakterien
seien dennoch wird labor fleisch immer
zu einem teil aus tierischen rohstoffen
bestehen aus den stammzellen doch die
forscherinnen und forscher hoffen dass
sich diese unter den richtigen
bedingungen immer weiter vermehren und
so kontinuierlich neues muskelfleisch
produzieren hochrechnungen von
niederländischen forscherinnen und
forscher zufolge könnten dann 150 rinder
die ganze weltbevölkerung ernähren 1,5
milliarden tiere sind es im moment ja
das ist wirklich wahnsinn
doch damit wäre tatsächlich in naher
zukunft künstliches fleisch im
restaurant und in supermärkten kaufen
können müsste noch einiges passieren
zum einen müsse die infrastruktur noch
ausgebaut werden um die produktion
überhaupt erst einmal effizient zu
machen die zucht müsste von den kleinen
petrischalen in größere bioreaktoren
da werden ja und im besten fall müsste
dann auch geguckt werden dass nicht so
viel energie verbraucht wird eine
bedingung dafür wäre dass entsprechende
startups finanziell gefördert werden und
labor fleisch müsste von den zuständigen
behörden in der eu als neuartiges
lebensmittel bewertet werden sicherlich
kein einfaches unterfangen das könnte
ein bisschen dauern dann gäbe es noch
eine weitere aufgabe das künstlich
hergestellte fleisch gesellschaftlich zu
etablieren um fragen aus den usa und
auch europa zeigen dass sie endlich 20
bis 50 prozent der leute fleisch aus dem
labor probieren würden fest steht
jedenfalls mit der konventionellen
fleischproduktion geht es nicht mehr so
lange weiter wie bisher die ressourcen
sie dafür gebraucht werden die reichen
schon bald nicht mehr aus und vielleicht
ist hier ein weg gefunden worden diese
katastrophe für mensch umwelt und tiere
zu beenden
bei pixum halte ich euch natürlich auf
dem laufenden zu diesem thema wenn er
kein video dazu und auch zu allen
anderen themen verpassen wollt dadurch
mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesst
nicht den auf die glocke hier geht es
weiter mit top sieben tiere auf drogen
der sehr lustiges video draufklicken und
ablachen würde ich mal sagen und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran